this week in our series on the new
normal we're looking at how the
coronavirus has affected the retail
industry and the way we shop
retail sales fell by record numbers last
month
and clothing stores led the way with a
more than 78 percent drop in sales from
march after stores shut down all across
the country
j.c penney became the latest national
retailer to file for bankruptcy
protection
as americans turn increasingly to
shopping online
however nordstrom is welcoming shoppers
back at dozens of its stores and maria
viral was there
for reopening in dallas
ready it's time
the reopening of this dallas nordstrom
was a hopeful reminder of the way things
used to be
for both customers and staff you know
we've been sitting in front of a zoom
screen for the last two months and i
just want to get some new clothes and
feel
like it's spring and summer and there's
some normalcy nationwide retailers are
trying to figure out what that normalcy
looks like for shoppers
in the era of coronavirus in san
francisco it's only curbside pickup for
now
but in this wisconsin toy store masks
are optional for customers
earlier this month kohl's opened dozens
of stores in several states
they've closed fitting rooms and
designated special hours for at-risk
shoppers
customer walks in and they'd like a mask
back at this dallas nordstrom employees
wore masks and gloves
ppe was available at the entrance for
customers
and there was a steady stream of
cleaning in every department
these doors aren't open no okay we are
limiting the number of people that are
in our building so one way in
and one way out and that helps you count
it helps us count customers in
at checkout a shield separates customers
from the sales clerk and of course
more hand sanitizer thank you everybody
wearing masks
a lot of people wearing gloves a lot of
sanitizer around
some people would say like this doesn't
feel like real shopping but
is this the unfortunate new norm that
we're dealing with right now well i
think that's hard to say i think we're
gonna be doing everything we possibly
can jamie nordstrom the president of
nordstrom stores explains
the new normal is a moving target we
might find that some of those things may
not be necessary
over the long term nordstroms opened up
in 1901 as a shoe store so it was
important to them to reopen
this department safely so here's how it
works let's just say you try on a pair
of shoes and you don't like it
that item goes into quarantine for 72
hours
before anybody else can try it on were
there any items that you guys decided we
probably need to put this on hold or
we're not selling this
we started with talking to a lot of
retailers in asia who you know are
are a few months ahead of us in this uh
there hasn't been any specific
merchandise that's been problematic i
think
mostly turned services you think in our
beauty department we do a lot of
makeovers
you're literally touching the customer
we can't do that right now
we do a lot of tailoring the retail
industry brought in nearly four
trillion dollars last year employing
roughly 52 million americans
matt shea is president and ceo of the
national retail federation
the group estimates 7 million retail
jobs
could be lost due to the pandemic as the
retail industry goes
i so goes the economy and we need those
businesses large and small
to support those communities and deliver
products and services but also
to create employment opportunities for
those millions of americans who will be
impacted if we don't
the retail industry supports more than a
quarter of the u.s
workforce and although nordstrom says
they have a strong online presence
they also tell us more than 70 percent
of their business
comes from brick and mortar stores just
like this one and that's why
they are opening 62 more stores later
this week
tony that's some good news and really
interesting report mariah you know i
know when you go shoe shopping you got
to make sure your style is there and
they have it in your size but as you
mentioned now you got to also make sure
that your shoe is not in quarantine
because some other customer
touched it in the last 72 hours really
interesting stuff the new normal indeed